you know what I want to know is how many
people are gonna dress like this for
their men in black reviews you know
that's going to be a thing rightfully so
in any case let's do this men in black 3
all right so after about I believe it's
been 10 years since men in black 2 came
out now we get men in black 3 and again
you have Will Smith and Tommy Lee Jones
they work for the men in black I love
the concept of men in black it's just
really cool whenever there's a UFO or
alien interaction these men and blacks
swoop in they exact your brain you
forget all about it here information
control for aliens among people now I
really enjoyed the first men in black
movie I just thought it was really cool
you know you kind of fall into it it's a
short-ass movie but you're like yeah a
lot of fun second movie was not as good
now we get to the third movie and how is
it for the first part of the movie I was
like all right I've seen all this before
this is clearly forced after 10 years
you're just hoping that the movies gonna
be better than what it is just cheap
jokes Will Smith all being Will Smith
ish because you know they're like hey
you be Will Smith ish he's like all
right I can do that I'd built a career
on being Will Smith ish so easy enough
but it lost his fun factor it lost a bit
of its flavor of what I liked about men
in black but I suppose because men and
blacks no longer noon then after 20
minutes gone all right yeah yeah yeah
here we are men in black 3 it's not as
good as I wanted to be Tommy Lee Jones
gets erased from time than Will Smith
has to go back to 1969 and that's when
the movie picks up and that's when I
actually had fun with it and liked it
because we have young Tommy Lee Jones
played by Josh Brolin and quite frankly
Josh Brolin just kills as Tommy Lee
Jones I think he's actually young Tommy
Lee Jones like young Tommy Lee Jones got
a DeLorean gun did to 88 and I was like
oh wow look at me I'm an actor that's
cool maybe I'll just stay in this time
and become another actor I'll name
myself Josh Brolin that makes sense but
I liked him as young Agent K because
he's not as jaded as old agent K is he
still has that I didn't know my name's
Lord kind of vibe about him but he still
smiled in a couple scenes it's like he'd
still enjoyed life I like seeing that
it's like everything I loved about old
Asian K mixed with a new young agent K
fact is not like that that is exactly
what it is
otherwise it like and when Will Smith
went back in time it brought me back to
what I liked about men in black 1 which
is ultimately the pop-culture references
in technology and they're funny in 1969
because it's the Men in Black Tech in
1969 so you have some laughs there and
the baddie in men in black 3 is the guy
from Flight of the Conchords I
don't know his name because I have never
seen Flight of the Conchords I'm gonna
be honest with you I just know the guys
in it and he doesn't sound like him but
you gotta admit when you see him you're
like holy it's the alien ghost
specter of Macho Man Randy Savage every
time he was on screen I just want him to
be like I got you for three minutes
three minutes to play time let me do
Slim Jim oh yeah it just made me laugh
dude looks like Randy Savage I liked it
other than that though he doesn't stand
out as the villain when I think about
men in black 3 I don't think of the
villain at all
I think of Will Smith and Josh Brolin
that's the men in black 3 movies and
there's this other alien I like too he
could see probabilities he ultimately
sees every scenario that could happen
but I liked him there's something about
his little dumb smile that I was like
yeah he's cool I'd hang out with that
dude by the end of the movie the way it
wraps up I was like I'm not quite buying
everything about this movie but in the
end I did have fun Will Smith and Josh
Brolin great chemistry I like them both
I like their characters I like the tech
humor in this movie if you're a fan of
men in black you're gonna enjoy men in
black 3 get past the first 20 minutes of
the movie and then you're gonna have a
good time in fact a good time no alcohol
required oh yeah is it as good as you
want it to be after a 10-year wait
probably not but it's still a fun movie
kick your feet back enjoy the ride
so have you seen the minim black movies
what's your favorite men in black movie
right now you have one in two but if
you've seen three one two and three
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more I have no
neuralyzer otherwise I'd neuralyzed you
guys if I did have the device that does
look substantially like a neuralyzer
I'd be concerned wasted opportunity
maybe but in the end just going to punch
the screen
you